hello rejects Greg Alva here no redos
yeah no reduce its checking my folks
Wendy I'm Wendy Collider videos the
movie couple a lot of movie talked watch
her movie yeah one of those things and
pick up Twitter questions on movie talk
yes exactly
today we're gonna do our top five
favorite comic book movies of all time
for me from my list I'm not choosing
this based off of like intellectual
analyzing I'm doing this based off
solely like the films that I'm really
stuck with me some of the films like put
on here I haven't seen in a few years
but these are like I took a lot of time
to actually think about this or up time
like 15 movies me too and then I was
like what are the five though that
really stuck with me so kick it off the
fifth one I have is the crow I grew up
on this film my parents did not care to
censor me when I was younger so I really
watched a lot of violence back then and
the crow was one of those films
this film was dark its stylistic I read
the comic eventually and it's fairly
accurate to the graphic novel and it
kind of looks like the graphic grin the
graphic novels on black and white but it
still kind of looks like the graphic
novel Brandon Lee is his last
performance and I thought he was really
[ __ ] cool in it man everyone wanted
to be Jerry from that film that I really
wanted to be him he made like clown
makeup what kind of cool actually there
was one of those like comic movies that
I feel like we don't really see now it's
kind of ugly it's kind of grim but it's
still very stylish at the same time and
individuals today to me are still very
impressed that the action could be a
little updated but the visuals are very
impressive the characters are gnarly
to me it's the I think this might be the
first convert movie I ever actually saw
my number 5 is actually Marvel's Iron
Man um it was just one of the first it
was it I mean Nexus spider-man the first
for me my introduction into the rest of
the MCU and I enjoyed it because it
mixed you know Hamill emotions
action and a little bit of human which I
can appreciate I feel like that film
does not get enough credit honestly
because even though it's not on my list
Iron Man to me I still highly respect
that film because there was so much
counting on that film they took a big
gamble with it but Robert Downey jr. in
it he only got paid five hundred
thousand dollars for that film now he's
the highest-paid actor right because he
was like it's still a year you're still
recovering from your whole past and then
they had Jon Favreau who had never done
a film on that scale or adds a little
bit to such expectations and they were
counting on this to kick off the MCU and
it did and it also had like the formula
the structure that a lot of the MCU
films have pretty much copy look what
it's brought them today
look what's wrong today exactly we're
about to get dr. Strauss should have
been on my list actually so even though
I think Captain America Civil War is
technically a better film than this it's
still my number four favorite film
that's Marvel's Avengers Assemble The
Avengers to me I primarily put this on
my list because of the experience I had
when I first saw one of the people that
went on opening night there's so much
hype around this this one was built up
for years that hands-down the most
anticipated comic book movie of all time
so many people just like the Avengers
new defenders Titans we had never seen
them all come on screen together this
was a huge ordeal and they pulled it off
most people were very much satisfied
there was a blast in the theaters it
amped up the action for those who didn't
really like Captain America the First
Avenger they really liked him in this
one the Hulk they finally nailed him
down perfectly
they had Black Widow in there where she
was much better in there than she was an
Iron Man 2 and they made Loki scary
yeah beyond those like technical
improvements even though Civil War to me
is like a better film I had a much much
way more fun time when I saw the
Avengers the first time in the theaters
do you feel that even though the airport
scene was really epic the long thing of
them fighting with these with the worms
the alien worms can remember what
they're called do you feel like that
with that whole sequence was better yeah
I think as a whole that sequence was
better because there's more there's more
weight to it even though we're like
they're all gonna survive there was
still more of a weight and even though
they're like Iron Man's going up and you
sacrificing yourself yeah like he's not
gonna die but there's a little part of
like maybe you'll die
just maybe to me even though the eye for
the airport sequence is [ __ ] awesome
I still think that shot where they go
around to all the Avengers doing their
separate thing oh good I think there's
something that's like the best shot out
of the whole MCU I literally felt like
it was the comic book coming to life
yeah it was the first time where I felt
like the MCU films had achieved that
that we're like the comics are here like
they did it yeah yeah awesome
I loved it for my number four I picked
the Dark Knight nice yes mainly because
of the Joker they finally got that
character to the dark gritty more modern
take then the Cesar Romero or the the
Jack Nicholson I'm not saying that you
know they're they're all just as iconic
but Heath Ledger really really delivered
it's interesting to think I always think
back especially now that suici spots
came out what Joker would have been like
what's the next evolution of the Joker
had Heath Ledger not past right although
you know like I think like everyone on
YouTube would agree Jared Leto is the
best Joker let that sink him that's
right I said it do I mean it yeah I
don't mean that number three for me is
the film that were I like to say before
there was Deadpool there was kick-ass
yeah I feel like a lot of people have
forgotten about kick-ass cuz yeah it's
not as big of it like a comic book or
the characters aren't as big as any as
Deadpool but still it was like an
r-rated adaptation of this comic book
that and it was very violent they did
some very edgy things in there and the
mean badass in the film was a
twelve-year-old girl and she was so cool
they did the they did something that I
just didn't see could never be done
they made a 12 year old girl the most
badass thing ever
okay it comes see what you can do now
kick-ass would be no stranger things
that's not sure that doesn't even make
sense in comparison really it works it
kind of works but anyway I was laughing
throughout it was very self-aware
you know meta at the same time Nicholas
Cage I thought had a really cool role
like when people look back and what's
the last cool Nicolas Cage film people
tend to reference kick-ass there's been
some good work he's done after kick-ass
but most people will reference kick-ass
and Chloe grace Moretz she wouldn't be
here if it wasn't for that so yeah
Matthew Vaughn would not be would not
have done an x-men first class if it
wasn't for his work on kick-ass or
anyone I got in Kingsmen either like he
really solidified a unique style for
that film and he showed that he really
understands comic books and he wasn't
afraid to push boundaries in it and you
got to quicksilver's in there that's
pretty oh my god one fact movies but my
number three I picked dread dread guys
actually saw this on Netflix because for
some reason I confused it with doom
do you remember doom yeah with the rock
yeah I confused it with that and I guess
maybe Karl Urban was in it too maybe
that's why I think yeah I think so um so
then my husband's like oh no you need to
watch Dredd this is such a good movie so
we watched it and my mind was blown and
I can appreciate an actor takes a role
that you know requires him to wear a
helmet that hides his beautiful face the
entire time
yeah able to deliver Lena Headey or
Headley however you say her last name
phenomenal very visually shot very
stylistic - it's cool it's like it's a
sci-fi comic book movie like in terms of
like like a dystopian kind of future
like it was really neat seriously loved
it but it doesn't be Judge Dredd with
Sylvester Stallone and Rob Schneider you
didn't see that oh it's so good OH
so my number two choice is a film that
really stuck with me throughout the
years there's a very unique theatre
experience and sneak into there cuz I
wasn't quite 18 yet
Sin City ah yes Sin City has got to be
the most loyal comic-book adaptation
ever put on the big screen it looks
exactly like a comic the script is
pretty much the comic books that it's
based on so much of the work in comic
book movies today are inspired by Frank
Miller's work you know whether it be 300
or even Zack Snyder being like oh we're
gonna based off the Dark Knight Returns
this is the best adaptation he's ever
had it gave us a chance for Frank Miller
should also be behind the camera so
that's why we got a great film like the
spirit that everyone loved Sam Jackson
in spell Johansson
he started it Frank Miller started
anyway well yeah Sin City to me it was
so cool like I didn't grow up on film
noir films but this film got me
interested in film noir and
understanding what the genre was
introduced in this like hyper visual way
and robbery as a Frank Miller put
together something that people have
attempted to do before but not everyone
could really get on board and they went
to a full maximum with it and we're like
we're gonna make this look exactly like
the comic this is gonna look like a
comic book brought to life and it was
[ __ ] awesome Bruce Willis was cool
this is this started to come back a
Mickey Rourke yeah liked it after that
then the wrestler came Clive Owen was so
[ __ ] cool in that film since a to me
was like it's super violent super dark
pretty twisted visually exciting it's
the ultimate comic book movie it's one
of those things where if you read the
comic you're gonna be thoroughly
satisfied when you actually watch the
film I feel like that movie had like an
all-star cast yeah these are the Toros
in there Brittany Murphy Jessica Jessica
elbow Michael Clarke Duncan yes Wayne
John Humphrey yeah
for my number two I picked Captain
America Winter Soldier Winter Soldier
story of Bucky comes back because I was
slightly disappointed in the Captain
America it was okay you know I like to
see an origin story it fell a little
flat for me
yeah I'm 4p the Captain America movie so
this movie totally redeemed it for me I
love just seeing how much Steve Rogers
cared for his friend at the lake he
would go to and just Sebastian's Dan
brings it every single time it's just a
really cool spy movie - yeah and for the
MCU was known for like infusing a lot of
humor throughout I think that's the most
serious film they've ever done and it
worked it didn't turn off audiences it's
like no we can make a really serious
epic movie and it really flipped things
and really shifted the whole direction
of the universe and I really feel like
no one was expecting them and they make
Captain America way more badass like in
the action and stuff like they actually
they really improved that's that's fine
because a lot of people don't really
like the First Avenger mm-hmm but a lot
of people might list the Winter Soldier
is like their favorite one I just wonder
if because Winter Soldier is set in
modern time and it had you know cameos
from like Black Widow and and the
characters we know now it's post the
first venture as it was just Chris Evans
yeah and I wonder if that's what's heard
some people off I thought they were just
kind of rushed through it the first one
yeah and then montage all the cool stuff
mmhmm yeah cool so we could have like
scene of you know like wait we just
thought those are like scenes that they
and they cut out took parts from the
scenes and put them in the trailer they
were realizing just show the montage in
the trailer yeah my number one is the
movie I have never seen a film more
times than the feeders than this film I
saw this film nine times
and that is one of Wendy's choices at
the dark night I adored this film
absolutely adored it I saw it six times
on IMAX it was the very if you guys
haven't been to a real IMAX theater you
gotta go because it's a totally
different experience when the film is
shot with actual IMAX cameras and this
was the very first film that ever did
that only a few scenes and IMAX cameras
then it was the most insane experience
because now when you see that in like
movie if you go to like a city walk or
something yeah you see it it's it's not
as big of a deal now when you when they
shoot it with IMAX cameras but every
single time I saw it in the first like
few weeks nine times every single time I
won an IMAX for that opening shot of
Gotham City the audience just stuff you
can hear everyone's murmuring and
shifting around girl it was terrifying
like holy [ __ ] we're really in yeah of
course Heath Ledger as the Joker all
defining he won the Oscar it's wholly
deserved it and despite what you feel
about Christian Bale's voice is still
the Batman voice you'll be in a padded
cell forever I know Kevin Connor on the
animated series and the games has the
coolest speaking Batman voice but the
Batman voice that people go to do has
become Christian Bale's voice that's
better
everyone does to do but even Ben
Affleck's little voice change everything
still kind of yeah has the raspily thing
going on
exactly and I really love that they made
other characters even more significant
and more importantly Gary Oldman as
Commissioner Gordon was awesome in the
film that moment when like there's a
word two-face has his daughter Oh Gary
Oldman's like crying and blaming himself
like that was a real heartbreaking
moment and two-face was really cool like
when we saw a face on screen we got
Tommy Lee Jones and Batman Forever which
is not good and then they really did a
great job with showing us who Harvey
Dent is and not focusing on two-face
yeah yeah to me it's the best comic book
film a long time it's a crime epic film
as well I think it was a first comic
movie to really blend a John rrah
like we're gonna take that this Batman
story but this is a crime role so let's
make it a crime movie more than its not
a superhero that's another thing I love
about it yeah it's like Batman's
categorizes a superhero but he's not
super he's just a skilful hero
you know so quotable once represent
quotable and definitely my favorite out
of the franchise and for my number one
comic movie I'm picking Deadpool
Deadpool nice class well yeah talk about
a comic movie that knows it's a comic
book movie so it's not taking us up too
seriously that's true
and props to the marketing team over
there yeah because it's probably the
best marketing I've seen for a comic
book movie it's the most edgy for sure
although you you need a span of serious
comic-book movies in order for Deadpool
to work yeah you know I'm gonna pave the
road yeah exactly cuz you can't if like
Deadpool was like the start I don't
think it would have worked
I wonder if without Green Lantern there
wouldn't have been Deadpool because
right yeah yeah that's true that's true
I mean Deadpool is a very special
magical film I remember I was watching a
movie fights
who's that Sasha Sasha programmer yes
she was on movie fights and she was
arguing that if a movie two were to get
a lot of funding for a sequel shoot that
she would have picked Deadpool or two
yes I was agree with what the other
people were saying that Deadpool is
something that like because of its low
budget only make fifty million dollar
budget they made a very just a real
story out of it it wasn't about
spectacle he's not even really a hero
no he's me as a hero yeah cuz he's not
he's not like on a heroic mission he's
on a revenge quest like technically
that's what he saw yeah he's a vigilante
he just ends up having to save his girl
by the end of the film yeah but through
most of it it's just a revenge mission
yeah I really love that film Deadpool
was awful saw it twice in the theaters -
that's incredible - when it's super
affordable super affordable that's the
only good thing that came out of x-men
origins Wolverine yes I remember when I
saw origins Wolverine before all the
reviews came out and I actually watched
it I hated the film and I was one of
those people who's like but Ryan
Reynolds was awesome in the film he's
only in it for a few minutes because me
right yeah and it took ten years but I
love that oh yeah it's like such a
fanservice movie and it's cool that a
fanservice movie was accepted by the
masses you know is it like the
highest-grossing r-rated film now yeah I
think so Passion of the Christ
I want to say it's that pool now okay I
love that he was able to break the
fourth one without it looking cheesy I
was worried about that was like oh let's
go he's talking directly to the camera
yeah they're gonna get tired of it I
never got tired to fight in fact I
wanted it more yeah I wasn't over you
ever see the movie uh Kiss Kiss Bang
Bang yes I did I really loved that film
but I feel like in the first half I felt
like Downey jr. breaks the fourth wall a
little too much and then and I was
worried about that too with Deadpool
like is he gonna do that too often to
the point where I get annoyed yeah but
now that was that was very very
well-crafted movie were you ever worried
about ed skrein or how you say his last
name I've screen we're just gonna go
within the villain Francis in the movie
how he was gonna be uh no I wasn't
worried about that
did you see transporter refueled no not
so great not serene I remember when Ed
was on a team of 300 yeah I know that
cuz I'm a huge gamer i watch every
episode he came through I was a little
worried about about his acting no more
fear I thought you did really well I
love what they did with I mean some
people complain that you know he's still
not the most definitive kind of villain
really I love that the film establishes
that in its opening credits yeah you
know like a British guy wears the same
towel yeah British villain British
villain yeah so you think you're it's
not like oh he's just gonna be typical
but then there were more layers to him
that made him interesting enough and by
the end you did want to see him die yeah
merciful I usually feel like in concrete
movies a villain like you're just
annoying and I want you dead and this
one you're lucky this guy deserves to
die yeah yeah this guy's ruin are two
main characters like like he deserves
death yeah alright guys well that's it
for our top five favorite card my movies
of all time here's a YouTube question
asked what are your favourite comic book
movies put them in the comments below
like this video share
we said all the necessary names in an
outro subscribe to the real rejects
become a rejected a Wendy is part of :
her videos and she has her own channel
called the movie couple where she does
movie talk trailer reviews with her hug
be not boyfriend I feel like feel like
something a lot of people start channels
together for just boyfriend and
girlfriend dangerous territory I'm
letting you know until you're married
and then you do it wait till you're
married cuz yeah something happened with
them it's not gonna just be like alright
you could have the channel no it's gonna
be like lawyers and [ __ ] I'll teach you
comments I'll take